The joe rogan experience and I,
and I'm not going to be because I tried,
uh,
we eat yeah.
Once two years ago and I stayed
hide for 14 days straight to God,
man.
Did you eat it?
14 days.
900 he smoked.
He wasn't a vaporizer.
Is that,
yeah.
Vaporize vaporizer.
Yeah.
And I say hi for 14 days and
I thought it doesn't right.
He doesn't,
I wasn't high.
Right.
Well hopefully it wasn't,
but I thought it was like
disconnected from reality.
Well sometimes that does happen and I
know a story about a guy who is a straight
laced guy who took some marijuana edible
so that he could get to sleep and he
had a real problem.
Like he got suicidal and freaked out
and became just irrationally anxious.
He had crippling anxiety and some
time for some time for weeks.
And he's a confident
guy and a very handsome,
big muscular guy.
Like he just like,
you would never imagine this
guy have any antianxiety.
I think some people have just the
chemistry of different individuals.
I wasn't bar for death and that's what
the doctor told me because I went to the
psychiatrist.
Wow,
you went to this like
I swear to God,
I'm dead week.
That week I went to the psych guy
through smell and I told him no,
I smoked that thing like 14
days ago and I still high.
And he,
he looked at me and he gave me some,
some cycle one.
He gave me some pills and I was like,
Oh,
if you stay high until tomorrow,
take these pills.
Because what he told me,
it's something that I didn't know that
he can be a trigger if you're has some
tennis of schizophrenia and a
psychopath or if you feel have,
which was not my case.
And He's told this is very rare,
but he can't happen,
which is not your case.
And I,
it was happy because of the up and the
next day I was okay and I felt okay and I
did it took the pills and it was crazy,
man.
It's crazy.
And I remember that I
decided to record it,
but I was like,
like,
Hey,
let me,
let me record what I'm thinking.
At least let's get some
good experience out of it.
And I remember that it
started to record and I said,
uh,
now I'm going to record
everything that I'm thinking.
And when I look at the cell phone,
it was 45 minutes,
45 minutes to talk.
And I didn't even realize I just
said that I'm going to record now.
And there was 45 minutes and when I
listened to like 15 days after that,
I was like,
I'm so crazy.
So crazy.
I'm going to die.
I'm never going to understand
on my son's talking,
talking to me right now.
Wow.
That was one hit of available.
No,
it was more than one.
A bunch of hits.
He was a bunch.
Oh,
you're too tall.
You're big.
You're like a 250 pounds.
So fucking use it a lot.
Oh,
so they were saying keep
hitting it because you're tall.
Because I wasn't feeling it.
Oh No.
But when I felt it,
I felt for 14 and you know,
having that belief does,
does add up to that.
I mean that's step one in my opinion is
visualize a nam believing it and on the
flip side,
having a negative self worth or a negative
opinion of what you're about to do or
a negative thought about the future
can also manifest all sorts of terrible
results.
Absolutely.
Gotta think placebo
effect is a real thing.
We know that,
right?
We know that if you really do believe
that you're going to get better because of
some sugar pill they give you,
there's a tangible result,
100% if you really believe that salt guy,
if the thing about all
that stupid shit is,
if you believe it,
it actually has an effect.
There's,
there's a lot of healers out there that
at least on paper are totally full of
shit.
But if you believe in these assholes,
yeah,
I can make a difference.
It's very slippery.
The human mind is such a slippery thing.
I mean,
and I'll go back to my
own experience and again,
I don't know how a femoral
are out there you want to get,
but I'm out there in
Antarctica 54 days alone.
Like I'm telling you I'm doing
this for this bigger purpose.
I'm feel like I'm tapped into that and
like legitimately there were moments,
at least for me,
whether I'm manifesting that in my mind,
whatever you want to call it,
that I am actually feeling energetically
uplifted by the people pushing me on.
Like there were days that were incredibly
hard where I would sit there and I'd
be like,
oh my God,
I don't know if I can
do this and I'm done.
Like boom.
Like I would get over,
I would hit with this
sort of larger purpose,
that's larger outcome and again,
like I'm not,
I'm not a super religious person.
I was actually raised on a hippie commune.
Like I come from a pretty
untraditional background,
but like the energetic field,
whatever you want to call that or if
that's just the belief in something,
you know,
the power of that.
Like I felt the strength
from those moments.
There was moments when my body's
switched from kind of being negative.
Oh my God,
another hard day out here.
it's minus 25 to tapping
into those flow states.
So again,
I don't,
I don't have perfect words for that.
Um,
you know,
I'm starting to try to build
my vocabulary around that.
But that energy,
I think it was derived
from what you're saying.
If you start to believe it,
if you can believe like,
hey,
there's a larger purpose in this,
or hey,
this blue force fields A's and one foot,
there is something that
if you can originate that
positivity in your mind that I
think can give us incredible
amounts of strength,
um,
and,
and then we can tap
into something greater.
And so imagine being this guy getting
medals and awards for helping create jobs
around the country and then realizing
that automation is coming like a tidal
wave and that your efforts that you're
getting applauded for really not going to
do the trick.
And then Donald Trump wins the election
in 2016 and for whatever reason,
in my opinion,
the media is just not being honest
about all the economic drivers.
They're blaming racism,
Russia base book,
the FBI.
And if you look at the voter district
data on a district by district basis,
there's a straight line up between the
adoption of industrial robots in that
voting district and the
movement towards Trump.
Like it's a straight economic story where
we blasted away 4 million jobs in the
swing states and Donald
Trump is our president.
So imagine being me and then
seeing that and being like,
okay,
I get it.
This is an economic,
technological story.
And then I went to
people in Washington DC.
I was like,
hey guys,
what are we going to do?
We're in the third inning of the
greatest economic and technological
transformation in the
history of our country.
And the third inning has
brought us Donald Trump.
The fourth,
fifth,
sixth endings are going to be horrific.
What are we going to do?
And then the answers I got were somewhere
between disappointing and horrifying,
where if you go to mainstream
politicians and you're like,
what are we going to do?
The answers I got were
literally number one.
We cannot talk about that.
Number two,
we should study that.
We cannot talk about that.
That was,
that's verbatim really.
Yeah.
And why were they saying that?
Because it seems alarmists
like anti progress or like,
you know,
you're like,
uh,
you know,
throwing stones at like,
like big tech companies and it's like,
I'm not throwing stones at anyone.
I'm just pointing out the fact.
So number one is,
uh,
so number one was can't talk about it.
Number two was need to study it.
And the number three was the
point you made a originally,
which was we must educate and retrain
Americans for the jobs of the future.
And then when I was like,
Hey,
we're terrible at that by the numbers,
then they'd literally be like,
well,
I guess we'll learn to
get better at it then.
And then I,
so I came back to my home in
New York City and I was like,
oh my gosh,
we are so backward and far gone as a,
certainly as a government.
Um,
and so then I was grappling with
it and I'm a parent like you are.
And I looked at my kids and I was like,
am I really going to bring
them up in this shit show?
Like,
is this really the,
is this really the plan?
And so then I was like,
okay,
how would you actually
solve this problem if you,
if you had to do so?
And so then I said,
okay,
universal basic income,
rebranded the freedom dividend after we
did a bunch of tests because it tests
much better as the freedom dividend
and universal basic income and,
and then try and make the,
the rules of the economy work better
for more people as fast as we can before
this automation wave really crescendo.
And then,
uh,
okay,
sure.
Um,
and then Alzheimer's,
you know,
uh,
again,
I know you're plus a plus 50,
so you know,
cheeks see Saint Jo has alzheimers.
I know that he wants to keep
doing this podcast for forever.
That'd be excused to stuff.
So,
so THC has been shown to inhibit the
formation of Beta amyloid plaques.
That's the,
you know,
the hallmark of Alzheimer's disease.
And then CBD CBD has also been
shown to be effective for um,
for Alzheimer's disease as well.
It was a rat study that was going to,
um,
get into,
but it's fairly fairly,
it's fairly detailed.
So you know,
it might be best just to say that it can,
you know,
help with rescue memory in patients if
you do use CBD meaning and that it may
actually reverse and that's
been shown before to,
they've done that in mice.
I got to interrupt you for one second.
Okay.
And I think you would agree this data is,
some of it's,
some of it sort of epidemiological,
some of it's preclinical,
it's very,
very early.
None of it really proves game and
just let me say I'm a clinician.
Okay.
If someone comes to me and
they have a concussion,
it's very frustrating just to say to them,
hey,
physical,
cognitive,
rest,
go home.
Okay.
It's really frustrating to
say that to someone also to,
you know,
the uh,
the high fat diet thing.
You know,
Joe and I both fall,
you know,
very,
very similar die.
So that's something I wanted
to share with regards to,
you know,
the,
the Alzheimer's disease,
we have really,
really poor medications for that
and we have an aging population.
So again,
like Alex,
like you want to look at everything,
which is what I'm doing.
Like I'm looking at everything and I'm
trying to make a clinical decision.
Am I using some things like without,
you know,
randomized control trials?
Of course I am.
But again,
I'm a clinician so I'm using,
you know,
mechanisms of action.
I'm using what I've see and clinic and
I'm using epidemiological studies and I'm
also taking into account what other
medicines do I have your base upon all the
data.
This seems to be an effective treatment
and I am absolutely not saying that you
as a clinician shouldn't do that.
Especially you're in Canada
at t cannabis is legal.
You should,
you should use your best judgment.
What I'm saying is that when we're
talking about policy decisions around
cannabis and Thc,
and to a much lesser extent,
CBD,
the advocacy groups have
seized on this very,
very preliminary data to to say a lot of
things about cannabis and THC that have
not been proven.
And you know,
a guy I know named Peter Bock,
who very smart,
uh,
he's a pulmonologist,
is at Memorial Sloan Kettering in New
York and he wrote a piece in the Wall
Street Journal,
a few,
Oh,
a couple of weeks ago talking about
cannabis is limits as medicine.
And he said something that I
thought it was so well put,
which is the reason why
people want cannabis to work
for Alzheimer's and cancer
and a bunch of things.
Where does,
where there's really no evidence that
it works is that we don't have good
treatments.
We want cures.
We want help.
We,
if we're clinicians,
I mean,
I'm not a clinician.
You're a clinician.
Want to be able to give people who
come into our offices something.
But that hope is not a
substitute for science.
It doesn't mean that it works.
And even you want,
you want your patients to have hope.
Okay.
But the advocates,
the people,
we're using this to push,
especially to push THC and to capitalize
on the public confusion around THC and
CBD.
I think that is a real,
it's a real
disservice to people.
Okay.
Um,
listen,
uh,
I think we covered everything.
So it's a complicated subject.
It really is.
And a,
I think it's really important to
discuss how complicated it is.
I don't,
I don't think there's a,
I've never heard such a detailed
analysis of all this stuff in,
in a way where you can get
two opposing people that are,
you know,
very civil about it,
but agree on certain aspects of it.
I think.
I think we really
highlighted all those things.